happy monday everybody it's not too soon
to start valentine's day
shopping and make some romantic plans
because we've got a chance of rain
next weekend so no don't get upset about
rain on valentine's day it makes it
romantic
beautiful skies out there nice and clear
for your monday morning and
we'll keep the sunshine for the first
half of the day more high clouds coming
in in the latter half of the day lots of
40s
nellis a little chillier in the 30s
prompts in the 30s mesquite's in the 30s
this morning
cold start to your monday but we'll have
mild afternoons most of the week up
around
70 degrees periods of clouds uh every
other every other day or so and then a
better chance of showers again coming on
the weekend
now these clouds are coming in this
afternoon tonight
and definitely on tuesday mid to high
level clouds covering up the sunshine
for your tuesday so get out there this
morning and enjoy it we had such a
beautiful weekend
highs in the upper 60s look at the deep
freeze over the northern plains the
upper midwest
temperatures in the single digits and
even below zero
is cold in that part of the country so
we can't complain
so we'll call it mostly sunny at a high
of 69 to near 70.
high clouds all day tomorrow more sun on
wednesday
thursday and then a slight chance of
some showers early friday morning then
mostly sunny
and that larger system a little stronger
into the weekend
slight chance of showers saturday and a
better chance of rain on sunday cooler
too
we'll drop into the low 60s maybe even
upper 50s by monday